acquitting to 1.6 billion tons of food
that spoiled on the way to the market
or expired in our refrigerators
or were simply thrown out by supermarkets and restaurants
at the end of the day.
Every single year, up to 600 million people
will get sick eating contaminated food,
highlighting the challenge that we have of maintaining global food safety.
And, maybe unsurprisingly,
the agricultural industry
is the single largest consumer of fresh water,
accounting for 70 percent of global usage.
Now, you'll be relieved to know
that the agricultural industry
and that the global movement by universities, companies and NGOs
is putting together comprehensive research
and developing novel technology
to address all of these issues.
And many have been doing it for decades.
But one of the more recent innovations in food production
being deployed in industrial parks in North America,
in the urban city centers of Asia,
and even in the arid deserts of the Middle East
is controlled environment agriculture.
Controlled environment agriculture is actually just a fancy way of saying
weather- or climate-proof farming,
and many of these farms grow food three-dimensionally in vertical racks,
as opposed to the two dimensions of conventional farms.
And so this type of food production is also referred to
as indoor vertical farming.
I've been involved in the indoor vertical farming space
for the past five and a half years,
developing technology to make this type of food production
more efficient and affordable.
This picture was taken outside of a decommissioned shipping container
that we converted into an indoor farm
and then launched into the heart and the heat of Dubai.
Indoor vertical farming is a relatively recent phenomena,
commercially speaking,
and the reason for this is that consumers care more about food safety
and where their food comes from,
and also, the necessary technology to make this possible
is more readily available and lower cost,
and the overall cost of food production globally is actually increasing,
making this type of food production more competitive.
So if you want to build an indoor vertical farm,
you will need to replace some of the conventional elements of farming
with artificial substitutes,
starting with sunlight.
In indoor vertical farms,
natural sunlight is replaced with artificial lighting like LEDs.
While there are many different types of LEDs being used,
the one that we decided to install here
is called "full spectrum LEDs,"
which was optimized for the type of vegetables that we were growing.
Also, in order to maximize production for a given space,
indoor vertical farms also utilize and install racking systems
to grow vegetables vertically,
and some of the biggest facilities
stack their production 14 to 16 floors high.
Now most of these farms are hydroponic or aeroponic systems,
which means that instead of using soil,
they use a substitute material like polyurethane sponges,
biodegradable peat moss
and even use inorganic materials like perlite and clay pellets.
Another unique aspects about these farms
is that they use a precise nutrient formula
that is circulated and recycled throughout the facility,
and this is pumped directly to the vegetables' root zone
to promote plant growth.
And lastly, these farms use
a sophisticated monitoring and automation system
to significantly increase productivity,
efficiency and consistency,
and these tools also provide the added benefit
of producing food that is more traceable and safe.
Some of the obvious benefits of growing food in this way
is that you have year-round vegetable production,
you have consistent quality and you have predictable output.
Some of the other major benefits
include significant resource use efficiencies,
particularly water.
For every kilogram of vegetables grown in this way,
hundreds of liters of water is conserved compared to conventional farming methods.
And with the water savings
come similar savings in the use of fertilizer.
One of the highest-yielding farms
grows over 350 times more food per square meter than a conventional farm.
And weatherproofing
means complete control of incoming contaminants and pests,
completely eliminating the need for the use of chemical pesticides.
And not to be mistaken,
these farms can produce enormous amounts of food,
with one of the biggest facilities
producing 30,000 heads of vegetables a day.
However, as with any new technology or innovation,
there are some drawbacks.
As you would imagine,
growing food in this way can be incredibly energy-intensive.
Also, these farms can only produce a small variety of vegetables commercially
and the overall cost of the production still is quite high.
And in order to address these issues,
some of the biggest and most sophisticated farms
are making significant investments, starting with energy efficiency.
In order to reduce the high energy usage,
there are efforts to develop higher-efficiency LEDs,
to develop lasers optimized for plant growth
and using even fiber-optic cables like these
to channel sunlight directly into an indoor vertical farm
during the day to reduce the need for artificial lighting.
Also, to reduce the labor costs associated with hiring a more sophisticated,
more urban and also more high-skilled labor force,
robotics in automation is used extensively in large-scale facilities.
And you can never really be too resource-efficient.
Building indoor vertical farms in and around urban city centers
can help to shorten the agricultural supply chain
and also help to maintain the nutritional content in vegetables.
Also, there are food deserts in many countries
that have little to no access to nutritious vegetables,
and as this industry matures,
it will become possible to provide more equitable access
to high-quality, highly nutritious vegetables
in even the most underprivileged of communities.
And finally, and this is really exciting for me personally,
indoor vertical farming can actually be integrated seamlessly
into the cityscape
to help repurpose idle, underutilized and unused urban infrastructure.
In fact, this is already happening today.
Ride-sharing services have taken hundreds of thousands of cars off the road
and they have significantly reduced the need for parking.
This is a farm that we installed in central Beijing
in an underutilized underground parking structure
to grow vegetables for the nearby hotels.
Underutilized infrastructure
is not simply limited to large-scale civil engineering projects,
and they can also include smaller spaces like idle restaurant corners.
This is an example of a farm that we installed
directly into the partition of a hotel entrance
in order to grow fresh herbs and microgreens on-site for the chefs.
Honestly, if you look around,
you will find underutilized space everywhere,
under, around and inside of urban developments.
This is a farm that we installed into an empty office corner
to grow fresh vegetables for the employees in nearby cafes.
I get to be a part of all these cool projects
and working in the agricultural industry
to improve access and affordability
to fresh and nutritious produce,
hopefully soon by anyone anywhere,
has been the greatest joy and also the most humbling
and intellectually challenging thing I've ever done.
And now that I've convinced you that agriculture can be quite sexy,
you'll be surprised and shocked to know
that I still have trouble
fully articulating how and why I decided to work, and continue to work,
in the agricultural industry.
But a couple of years ago, I found a rather unique answer
hiding in plain sight.
You see, I read an article
about how your name,
particularly your last name,
can have a strong influence
on everything from your personality to your professional career.
This is my Japanese last name:
Oda.
And the characters translate literally
into "small farm."
(Laughter)
Thank you.
(Applause)